happy april 1st  the pyramids were built to be tombs  copper chisels cut through granite like  butter  joe biden got the most votes in u.s  presidential election history  masks have saved billions of lives  the shot works  epstein did not kill himself and  conspiracy theories do not exist  in fact fully ingesting fluoridated  water is indeed necessary for good oral  hygiene  jfk probably died of a brain aneurysm  the zapruder film autopsy photos likely  doctored i mean everybody knows  that media and government propaganda  died with hitler and that cozy little  bunker and by the way if we simply would  nuke russia if it saved one person's  life  it would be worth it  happy april 1st everyone